how's it going reject nation is john
humphrey and our good friend dan cyber
here out in front of the el capitan
theater greg is not with us at the
moment he's holding the camera because
during the movie
he had allergic reactions
on benadryl so not to the movie itself
just to an actual burger but anyway the
movie the movie itself was a delight dan
is a bob's burgers fan i am a noob i've
seen maybe one or two episodes i had a
blast but dan what'd you think it's
great if the music is fantastic the
opening song is playing in my head over
and over again if you're a fan or not
it's a good movie absolutely i've heard
this described as like a two-hour
episode it does have that feel but if
you're into the humor and if you're into
the animation there's a lot to
appreciate there's some really fun but
also some touching sequences as well i
laughed very hard as did i recommend it
go see it this face doesn't say laughter
but it is and also the voice cast
obviously you can't go wrong uh hey
do you like a good burger you like a
good pun